a friend of the show former NFL
quarterback CFL star and USC legend
Shaun Salisbury joining us hi Shaun
every time I come on there's this
there's this introduction you said dead
air and then signs coming on here but I
have a listen to me Dan I have a
particular set of skills if you talk
about my career and how bad it was I
will find you I thought you were sending
me one of your CFL jerseys I am at the
blue-gray Cup
yes it's in the process and what I
wanted to I wanted over your right
shoulder like a burden when it comes on
there's not Marino's or elders I wanted
have you ever did you ever sit down and
talk quarterbacking with Montana or
Elway or Marino oh yeah a lot not Joe
not a lot of times just like an
interview but every single year I talk
with Marino a lot of okay but what do
you say do they look at you like how do
they look at you because you didn't play
too much in the league but you did play
[Laughter]
well I got to Train Adam Sandler for
loanshark you didn't say and I say well
at Stanford when I was a sophomore at SC
and you were a senior I got you their
players a week at your expense in Denver
and Favre I never lost you and Steve
Young I never lost you so those are
about my only three or four wins at the
league so I use that as a crutch I
wasn't very good but I did play good
against a couple of the good ones yeah
well the conversation doesn't stay on me
long and I was their caddy basically but
I somehow remember the good stuff and
and watch more than play than I did it
myself actually studied formula them
then
well I and I always have said that
you're one of the better football
analysts out there you you have a great
eye for for looking at these things
certainly at the quarterback position
I can't imagine where okay
I mentioned this that dak Prescott that
my advice to doc Prescott not that he's
asking for it but the financial logic I
would have is bet on yourself and with
that great offensive line Amari Cooper
and Zeke Elliot in why not sign a
two-year deal and let's say we guarantee
it for 63 million dollars new TV deal
comes up 2020 you go back into the
marketplace you bet on yourself and then
you sign that big five-year deal what do
you think of that logic instead of you
know dak signing a five-year contract
with the Cowboys I love your logic Dan I
love it and I personally I may be in the
minority but I actually think that
Prescott is the most underrated
quarterback in the NFL and when I was
neighbor when he came out this year I
had him as the second quarterback on my
rankings he ends up going the fourth
round the one weakness for me with him
is can you carry a team like Rogers or
Brady or those guys that for five or six
weeks there Mike Trout you know that
they can carry a team hand back to it
and right now I think that's the big
question mark but he's pretty accurate
underneath get better throw on the ball
down the field but wait he can can he
carry a team no right now we can't okay
that's my thing is it I can't see 40
million a year but hey ask the moon they
get a couple stars in the process I like
your style better because the more
numbers he were numbers to the league we
want Super Bowls but it killed any
numbers oh my gosh you're not the
quarterback you give me numbers and no
Super Bowl well you're not a winner
we want both so what
gives him top running back a number one
receiver he gets more settled in in the
offense again confidence continues to
grow it's like the Kurt cousins approach
one last year guarantee sixty million go
do your thing
throw me a forty five hundred yard
season and give me deep into the
playoffs or a possible Super Bowl
doorstep and now we can talk and then
the money will be bigger than he's
asking for now I do think there's
something to prove but I also think he's
extremely disrespected when you look at
who's compared to all of us he's not a
top ten guy but that Prescott's a good
player but the one thing holding him
back is the can eukaryote team if it
doesn't play this let's say held out for
six games can you get us to four and two
or five and one I think that's the
biggest question Michael mark or why
people are afraid to pay him that kind
of money all right let's say the open
market you can have dak Prescott or
Jared Goff same money
Prescott right now I'm concerned about
golf well close unassuming Bay is one of
the best in the world of what he does
but there's some DNA when it comes to
closing out games I got to see more of
from golf right now if I have to to to
lead my team could God could Prescott
gotten the Rams were exhausted last year
absolutely and I'm not sure he would
have went away and hid in the Superbowl
like we saw a little bit of the Rams
office I'll take Prescott over golf all
right Carson when Jack Prescott same
money Prescott I mean O'Quinn in my
opinion has a bigger where there's no
ceiling he's got a bigger potential and
places to reach I think he's an MVP guy
the thing is so Dan if you're not
available it's hard for me to consider
you one of the top five or six guys in
league which has the ability but I got
to have him on the field that doesn't
miss games when Smith some antennas his
last couple just but when he's out there
he is an alarming talent and he has a
through the roof guy great leadership
people love him I think if you had the
same amount of money or even a loom I
tell you when smore if you're telling me
who's going to give me to a Super Bowl
quicker and play in that Super Bowl I
take wins quits first but I have taken
prestopnik work off talking to Shawn
Salisbury joining us Dan Patrick show
what do you expect what do you need to
see out of Baker Mayfield this year I
would like to see those guys playing in
the mill January this is I love this
school I think they're the best team in
the north I think that the the
production will match the height now
hype says their Super Bowl champions but
I think they're going to get close to it
because I love his swagger Danni wins
and when people say break down what you
need in a quarterback when they say what
are the traits
well my traits are number one are you
mentally and emotionally tough enough to
handle booze from your own crowd or
people throwing stuff at you or the dog
peeing on your leg or whatever it is
because you've had a bad first half can
you come out and win for me he's got
that he's accurate big arm swagger his
teammates believe in him now people are
going to say does the overtalk where
he's going to be locker room fodder
antenna but that's ok because I think
that drives and he comes at it from a
walk-on personality and approach then
there's always a chip on his shoulder
I think he's going to be a star I think
he's going to have a ring on his finger
before long I think the Pittsburgh
Steelers that they may be looking up at
the division champ in the round and I
love disparate but I love what this
team's done and how they're building and
it starts at that position this is not
saying you can't be this good and
continue to make this many plays for me
they're a mid January playoff team and
probably a little bit of experience away
from being us looking at the February
door they're kind of like the Chiefs
were last year they're close and now
they've got a chance to go over the top
I think the Cleveland Browns are on the
come and I think they're going to be
very difficult to deal with don't blink
if they're in the middle of January
still playing football I am getting more
and more concerned about Andrew Luck
here that it was just a calf and it was
just a calf and al Jim Irsay the owner
said well it's a small bone in there is
Andrew Luck starting week one against
the Chargers III I hope so Dan but I'm
gonna tell you this team goes from as
much as I respect the backup quarterback
position because I understand it with
that with Andrew Luck they are the
division champions in my mind without
him and now there's two or three other
tools that are said we've got a
legitimate source now he's not going to
miss much time as he does I think he
will start but I was you
you know what's soft tissue and the
captain won't worried will does it creep
down of the Achilles and even though
it's on his left leg which is not his
plant leg you still got a the
follow-through and the finish and how
does that affect accuracy and remember
dental in the shoulder oh it's not that
big a deal
a year later he wasn't throwing so yeah
I'm concerned and while people think
well is it soft tissue and the nagging
part of soft tissue you know I've been
through many surgeries well they start
saying bone and it's not ready and then
I'm not worried about preseason games
what I am worried about is the
conditioning and the mind and the mental
and the physical part and don't work
hard and he knows what's going on but to
be able to we just don't plug him in and
they want to say let's go back and do it
again this thing's built for success
long range success yes I am with you I'm
more concerned now that Andrew Luck than
I ever thought I'd be I thought it was
gonna be no big deal time awesome camp
this is serious because no Andrew Luck
no playoffs if this is an extended
injury for the Indianapolis Colts does
your helmet matter that much well I
played with it wore leather helmet there
and then I played where there were a
Billy Kilburn face pass I think the
comfortability does you know you put it
on and you get the headache and it
starts to Pantera maybe somebody doesn't
like the way the visuals out of it come
I think this is this is ridiculous
everybody adjusts just like doing
business you doing life's to do with
rules you do with salaries to do with
new quarterback you're just this is this
is much ado about nothing I understand
comfort we only all wanted to be perfect
as uniform to fit right but then
adjustments when I played in high school
and you know this suspension helmet so
what means thanking them so then you put
on the bike helmet you pressurize it and
then the next thing in the next thing
yeah we don't like it to fit perfect but
you make a lot of money about 50 million
to deal with it find a helmet that fits
I don't like to build an excuse for a
great football player I hated as a
matter of fact yes matters yes there's a
comfort level but there's also a point
time we beg on athletes to overcome
adversity and to deal with change
Antonio Brown and anybody else has to
deal with teams if all the other dudes
can do it you can do it too and it's
gonna that affects this game that he's
got the type of player competitor I
thought he wasn't that I think he is
it's all the last long and he knew he
wasn't going to retire but
always win but these players would take
performance over protection if I said to
you that you're gonna have a less safer
helmet but you're going to be able to
perform better I'm assuming most of
these players would take the performance
part of this nine out of ten would say
I'll take performance as opposed to two
extra pounds on my helmet the extra
thickness
Dan it even gets to the point that when
you dress it in the locker room and you
put your helmet on and get a look at
yourself some of these helmets you know
you like the look of it honestly too
visible for some guys that it doesn't
quite fit right like my tower doesn't
look right what's it gonna look like
when I'm running around even that you're
100% correct if they said well it
increases 60% concussion wise it's where
your old helmet as opposed to the new
one but it's going to feel good 90
percent of the players in this league
would say ah I'll take the I'll take the
comfort and how I look and feel as
opposed to that concussion because it's
never gonna happen to me only interests
happen to somebody else I agree with
them I do the same thing give me comfort
over protection I'd probably do the same
thing yeah did you wear a protective Cup
when you were backup I did with the bars
left fielders in baseball wear cups but
running back running through the line
where hands are a flying and they're
Mitch Kupchak and grab and jump all the
time never cuts and you know what's
crazy Dan at no time in my career and I
know you're going to make the climate
well shod you want on the field you get
where the cup is at no time in practice
or a game have I ever been hit there to
where I got a stomach ache like you
would with a ball hit it wrong yeah it's
weirdest thing I have never watched a
player put a cup in and football in my
life I don't know one that's ever wore
one and I didn't need one because the
clipboard protected me on the sidelines
I didn't need it out and then when you
picked out your visor to wear on the
sidelines like how did you choose your
visor well I put mine up against the run
do game mullet my mullet was the best in
the NFL I can guarantee even the prime
but I didn't wear the visor the visors
just didn't look right I needed to pull
the Hat down like a closer in baseball I
was that hot bad
holder's visor guys I wanted the hat
pulled down boy I looked a lot tougher
and that's why I didn't buy sirs my
advisor six guys hitting pitching wedges
into greens not four quarterbacks on the
sideline
he's Shawn Salisbury morning Drive
hosted Sports Talk 790 in Houston always
great to talk to you Shawn thanks for
joining us nad Shawn Salisbury for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]